I was notoriously bad with technology.
One day I felt I should challenge myself.
What if I study computer science?
I have become a facilitator
for four periods.
We enjoy sharing with fellow women.
My name is Vitalia Eka Wardhani.
I am 18 years old.
The mindset of my family is:
you don't need to pursue higher education
because Indonesian women on average
have to get married after graduating from school.
Many women in the world have progressed.
So, I thought: "If they can do it..."
"why can't I?"
Many girls want to be a developer.
They often approach me and say,
"Hey I have an idea!"
So I invite them to join us
so they can learn how to
make their own app.
I found this class through
friends on social media.
It's pretty difficult.
I want to know more
about Android Studio
because we don't learn much
about it in campus.
After I finish studying I plan
to share what I've learned from this study group.
Many cities in Indonesia have been left behind,
and I want to teach in these areas.
Please come in.
Whether it's here at campus
or in Indonesia Android Kejar.
I'm really happy I can share with fellow friends.
Like that.
For women in Indonesia
my advice is:
don't be afraid to chase your dream.
If other people can do it,
then why can't you?